have any idea how hard it is to actually
be let me make this clear do you have
any idea how hard it is to actually be
no [__] a man and I say this and
women go oh yeah dude as soon as most
women encounter any kind of problem the
first thing you do is turn to a man
their man their dad the mechanic the
police a man if you actually put a woman
from a problem and go no men they're
like oh sh whoa [__] it's a mental
breakdown men day after day especially
if you're a high level man let me make
it something clear from my life I'm
talking from personal experience I'm not
just looking after me I'm not just
looking after my chick I'm the guy and
about 300 people's phone books that they
call when anything big goes wrong you
get arrested in Russia you need
extraction from Ukraine you need a
million dollars whatever it is
Kazakhstan abduction they called me I'm
the first phone call I'm fixing 400
different lives I'm a Problem Solver
chicks can't fix [__] any of this
[__] right